we were here at comic con and i'm so
excited roxy hello i am here i this is
i'm experiencing comic-con with miss
comic-con right now have you been to
comic-con i came last year was my first
time i said i was going to dress up this
year so this year it's your job to find
me at home the good thing is there are
so many awesome things inside of here
that we can get you there's t-shirts
there's just so many options
full out outfit okay all right and
you're dressing up too
all right
oh my gosh so i am so excited right now
oh my god
this is awesome
i'm a huge like a movie fantasy lego
movie lego movie are you kidding me i
love the lego movie we made it to lego
booth and actually the unikitty doesn't
even come out until sunday but they gave
me one i am speechless i'm so excited
look at him she totally is into this
kitty right here okay we have shirts
high and
and we found her and tell us what
happens okay you can also switch her she
switches yeah it switches from cutesy
kitty to cheersy kitty
i kind of want a kitty of myself too can
i have one
tank top oh my god oh my god
i'm gonna go get you a little something
to wear and i will meet up with you in a
second okay oh my gosh remember the
family show oh door don't worry
okay
we're gonna get roxy and i just need so
so happy hoodie well she goes and does
another interview
it looks so good oh my god they have so
many new hoodies
thank you so much she's gonna be so
excited so i will be back to come and
visit you guys soon
no it's all safe it's i so these are the
hoodies i designed this year for comic
con so
if you need a different size you can go
and get a different one i love it you
designed it yeah there's also some
leggings in there too so i didn't design
the leggings but put on the whole outfit
like you're set i'm set thank you
mission complete you now have somewhat
of an outfit and i have a bag yeah i
officially have a comp combat you have
officially comic-con made it
this is my first i just want to thank
justine this is my first comic-con bag
yeah
roxy was looking for them and now here
they are and she's busy doing an
interview she just missed her chance i
bet she is crying inside
and she sees them but look at her she's
being real professional doing her job
she missed the turtles
oh hello
this is a nice hotel
holy swanky city oh my god in the view
no
well let me put my clothes back on so uh
i'm
starving oh me too but like i don't want
to leave we're not leaving we're gonna
order room service then we go to the
fashion show because i have to update or
have to upload these videos for for
entertainment tonight that's what i was
trying to do and i can't get on the
wi-fi we've just arrived at the hot
topic her universe nerdist
fashion show so jen show me your outfit
we need to see oh let me put this on i
just thought like a little can you rip
the paper yes we're both actually
wearing her universe dresses and we went
on the marvel theme today so i cannot
wait to show you jenna as soon as she
gets that bad for that thing i got it
yeah okay let's see it
ready okay hold on let me get the step
and repeat okay great looks good okay
give me a spin oh that looks nice really
great looks good oh wow wow
we're here we're here i think she's
happy
fashion show is about to start the
audience is now filling up this place we
just got a preview of everything that
they're gonna be walking down the runway
in and it's awesome it's so amazing
these people are still talented
foreign
uh
so
foreign
uh
all right the fashion show's over we're
now visiting the xbox lounge and then
i'm gonna go to bed because i'm
completely exhausted we have another
cool day tomorrow for comic con are you
ready i am actually
great
we'll see you tomorrow